steve on parle et vous parliez de
dédiabolisation avant il y avait une
phrase qui circulent et par mal chez
vous à l'assemblée nationale
rassemblement national que vous parliez
de l'ump vous disiez finalement en
matière d'émigration pourquoi les
électeurs préféreraient la copie à
l'original maintenant y'a zemmour je
vais vous retourner la question pourquoi
les électeurs vous préférerez vous a
donc l'original du coup eric zemmour
gênant et je vais vous répondre la même
chose les électeurs préféreront toujours
l'original à la copie vous êtes là vous
parle nous n'avons pas attendu eric
zemmour pour mêlant plus radical sur
certains sujets que vous portiez
historiquement et plus révèle hélas ne
veut pas dire être plus réaliste je
crois que nous avons porté le thème de
l'immigration au coeur du débat
politique au moment où c'était
pratiquement un gros mot de le faire
appelez-vous un tout ce que les leaders
du rassemblement national et du front
national avant lui ont subi comme mots
un peu durs parce qu'ils évoquaient
l'immigration ses conséquences en termes
de coût social ses conséquences en
termes civilisationnel ses conséquences
en termes d'insécurité mais nous n'avons
pas abandonné le sujet marine me marie
le pen lui même est prêt à soutenir eric
zemmour alors il est prêt j'ai vu
l'interview il est prêt à soutenir
zemmour s'il est au second tour bon
aujourd'hui c'est pas l'hypothèse la
plus probable vous aussi le sauvetage
vous allez voter
d'abord je vais terminer ma phrase
confiante sur l'immigration quand même
parce que c'est un rallye très heureux
en 13 août en reparler au barreau par
les bords mais très heureux qu eric
zemmour nous rejoignent sur les constats
tant mieux plus on est nombreux plus ça
montre que notre discours a porté ses
fruits et qu'il est dominant dans
l'opinion publique et c'est le cas et
c'est pour ça qu'une des premières
mesures présentées par marine le pen
c'est le référendum sur l'immigration
pour que les français se prononcent
enfin on va reparler mais restons un
petit peu sur zemmour ne va pas faire
toutes les missions servent aujourd'hui
rassurez vous mais quand même à la l'air
embarrassé vis-à-vis de lui ont
l'impression qu'elle sait pas par si je
puis dire par quel bout le prendre elles
n'osent pas l'attaquer
elle alla jouer l'indifférence on a vu
que ça finalement ça lui a permis de
séjour de progresser est-ce qu'elle va
changer de stratégie et puis par
ailleurs elle essaye de temps de plus en
plus vers les jeunes sont les électorats
on l'a vu hier sur tik tok vous disiez
dans le plancher mais elle est aussi la
tête dans tic tac à l'euro
[Musique]